leaders 190 countries have agreed to
apply the deal that aims at limiting
global warming but many including
climate scientists are warning there
isn't a specific enough plan with how to
get there
the science says that 1.5 degrees is
going to be incredibly difficult we
would have to stop extracting and
burning tomorrow time to do something
now it's a point when we say we have to
change our way of life radically because
of the way it's the future is
compromised for everybody what do we
want what do we want it now a lot of
people say that there are other more
pressing issues war poverty racism than
climate change and climate change is
really just sort of you know it's it's a
slow-moving thing you can't separate
those those different elements rhyme and
change a galvanized saw those problems
those problems are made worse they are
increased through kind of changes you
can't separate war and climate change or
poverty climate change climate change
affects the poorest people they've
polarized Society increases the war it's
a violent struggle it might be a slow
process boy there's no escape to the
violin
specifically your from Kenya yeah what's
the situation in Kenya when it comes to
climate change and fossil fuel
extraction yeah right now as we speak in
Kenya we experiencing a lot of flags and
this is all because of climate change
and it's because also people want to go
for money fast we are looking at money
not looking at our claim they are not
looking at the biodiversity not looking
at mother nature and the mother asked
that we have